[Music]
your next contract there's a possibility
that you will be the highest paid
quarterback in the history of the league
yeah well there's a great potential of
that we'll see we'll see what happens
well how does that does that make you
feel good that means that well you know
it's not like i make me feel bad
that was last month on tonight's show
with jimmy fallon russell wilson the
seahawks quarterback there and chris i
got to give you credit i mean i it was
easy for me to say hey based on that
answer this is what russell wilson wants
he's sending a message you took a next
level and said the question was planted
we don't know that we're surmising we're
speculating that the question was
planted by russell wilson's people so it
would even be out there so they'll have
a chance to send that message because
the bottom line is this russell wilson
has provided a deadline to the seahawks
of today for doing a long-term contract
peter king reports in football morning
in america that the or else isn't simply
that he won't sign a long-term contract
this year or next year it said he will
never
ever sign a long-term deal with the
seahawks which means that he inevitably
will sign a long-term deal with someone
else which bolsters what we reported
over the weekend that the seahawks
believe he does want to play somewhere
else and if they don't give him what he
wants or if he wants so much that they
can't give him what he wants that's the
message russell wilson at some point
likely to play for another team the only
question is how does it play out trade
free agency does he hang around a couple
more years under the franchise tag we'll
see how that goes but without that
long-term deal today it's a matter of
when not if in my opinion russell wilson
is gone from the seahawks chris yeah i
mean
it's crazy you know i did not expect
russell wilson to be giving the seahawks
this type of ultimatum certainly
especially a guy you know who's been
very pro-organization probably a little
two-pro organization i mean he did he
gave the team probably too friendly of a
deal the first time around and he's
probably a little bitter towards that as
well uh but hey where there's smoke
there's fire and there's just been too
many things this off season whether it's
jimmy fallon and that which was a
planted answer i i you know again i'm
not even gonna planted question at least
certainly looks that way uh the way it
played out okay there was rumors early
on in the off season about you know the
new york giants and russell wilson we
have jack del rio coming out last week
don't be shocked if there's a trade i
know you and i have heard things behind
the scenes right so uh and then you know
again you hear things about his wife
sierra who of course is a big deal
herself and a phenomenal singer and all
that to where she wants to get out so to
me when you start to hear multiple
people multiple different reasons about
russell wilson maybe getting out of
seattle hey i don't know how much of
it's true but i think some of it's true
there's some truth there altogether and
it certainly seems if russell wilson
made this kind of demand or drew this
kind of line in the sand that yeah it's
almost sending a signal that he wants to
be out of seattle maybe right now or at
the very least at the end of next year
yeah i had heard last may that there was
regret on his part that he had done a
long-term deal the last time around now
the last time around the deal he did
21.9 million in new money that was just
under aaron rodgers 22 million per year
as the high watermark at the time the
problem is he started to be leapfrogged
as did rogers by guys like derek carr
matthew stafford jimmy garoppolo kirk
cousins rogers got his long-term deal
now at 33 and a half million wilson's
still at 21-9
and i think wilson after seeing what
kirk cousins did going year to year and
forcing his way to the market is kind of
fascinated with the idea of doing that
reluctantly engaging in contract talks
with the seahawks and making
significant demands and i think one of
the things it's going to take to keep
him chris a commitment by the seahawks
that there will be a set percentage of
the salary cap that he will get he'll
have a floor that is a negotiated hard
dollar amount
but as the cap goes up and there's three
factors to keep in mind new cba new tv
deals and the constant growth of
legalized gambling seven states
currently have it legalized 23 more have
it in the hopper the revenue
opportunities for the nfl will mushroom
and that means more money available
under the salary cap which means more
quarterbacks will be leaving russell
wilson in the dust even if he gets 34
million without that percentage
commitment as we get through some of
these big events coming up that will
drive the salary cap higher you're going
to see baker mayfield patrick mahomes
desean watson not in that order get more
than russell wilson so you protect
yourself with that percentage and i
don't think it's an unreasonable request
no one's ever gotten it others have
asked for it and if the seahawks want to
keep russell wilson they're going to
have to agree to it yeah well good luck
i don't think pete carroll and john
schneider are going for that unless the
owner ownership gets involved but again
here's the biggest point i want to make
and i think this is where the league's
going to go i mean the the fact the the
the proof is in the pudding you want to
talk about teams with quarterbacks with
team-friendly deals and their success
well let's go through it hey the two
quarterbacks in the super bowl this year
team friendly deals jeff i mean we know
about tom brady okay all the times
they've been in the super bowl you got
the rams how about the two times the
seattle seahawks were in the super bowl
of course with russell wilson that was
still rookie contract how about the
philadelphia eagles who won the super
bowl just two years ago that was had uh
very favorable you know friendly
contracts for the quarterback situation
about their baltimore ravens who won the
super bowl joe flacco rookie deal oh the
quarterback he was playing against colin
kaepernick guess what rookie deal so
you're seeing recent success here
throughout with teams that are winning
super bowls in the final four in the
final game whatever it may be
i just gave you a handful of examples of
teams that are doing it i don't think
seattle's going to budge on this there's
no way uh
and um yeah i just don't think john
schneider and pete carroll the type of
guys that are gonna they're not afraid
to make bold moves richard sherman gone
earl thomas gone michael bennett gone
you know marshawn lynch gone i just
nothing in their history says oh they're
gonna make it about one player i know
bobby wagner's there but he plays middle
linebacker he's still really awesome
he's certainly not going to command the
type of money that uh russell wilson or
a top-tier quarterback is so for me it's
looking like this is on the outs and uh
this is i you know the way it looks
right now april 15th i think russell
wilson this is it in seattle either he's
done this year or he's done here in the
next few weeks
well here's the thing though all those
other guys once they were
were gone they had somebody that they
could come in and replace him with now
they had a hard time replacing marshawn
lynch and and now eventually they've got
some guys there who can do it but if if
russell wilson is not the quarterback
you know who the other option currently
is on the roster yeah it's uh it's uh
paxton lynch right paxton lynch paxton
freaking lynch and not that he would be
the starter come week one but if you
trade russell wilson who is your starter
going to be and i think that's why
this year he probably stays i i can't
yeah it seems hard
how do you let him go this year but you
know if he really doesn't want to be
there and they sense he doesn't want to
be there
why what a weird lame duck season this
would be because if he stays this year
without that long-term contract i i you
know how effective is he going to be in
the locker room it's almost like a head
coach yeah he doesn't have a contract
beyond the the given year how much
leadership how much authority how much
weight do you have when people know this
is it i don't know but uh that's a real
question yeah but if you do move on from
russell wilson you got to have somebody
else who can come in and take over and i
don't know how they would sign you're
right or draft or whoever whatever they
would do what would they do yeah that's
no that's the big issue you're right
there's no other option out there right
now unless they have some master plan
that we certainly can't put together or
do anything like that you know to your
point about the lame duck season i think
that's a legitimate question i get it um
and yes you know i think there's going
to be guys that are like oh you know the
hell with him he's going to be out of
here next year but i don't think it'll
affect you know leadership or at the
very least russell wilson's going to
want to win football games he still
wants to be considered the best
quarterback in football or in that
conversation so he's gonna put his best
foot forward but it might not go that
long of a waste of guys making personal
relationships with them that way where
they're just gonna make well he's gonna
be out here in a few months there's no
point in me you know trying to be his
best buddy or whatever may uh but i
still think that so what do you do what
do you do if you're the seahawks what do
you do if you don't sign into a
long-term deal do you keep him for one
more year or do you see what else is out
there and just hope for the best i think
right now if i'm the seahawks just you
know uh i would go keep them for this
year
and you continue to weigh options and
see what happens i mean that you know
whatever it may be uh you know whether
they
whatever trades however it may be if
there's somebody that's out there and
you know becomes available in training
camp whatever it may be as far as a
young quarterback maybe they could make
a move right there gosh i don't know if
there's some trade talks going in the
works right now before the draft into
the draft then maybe they can make a
move but i think right now just as far
as it stands yeah i'm going into the
year with russell wilson as my
quarterback i'm the seattle seahawks i'm
not going to pay him too much money and
uh we'll see where this goes at the end
of the year but i don't think the
seahawks are scared to move on from
russell wilson
i god what how amazing that is
especially for the other teams in the
nfc west it was only a matter of time
before someone i felt like have the guts
to make this type of decision and i
always felt like the seattle seahawks
schneider and carol would be the two
that would flirt with it and we'll see
where it goes
well and and who knows they haven't
blinked yet yeah maybe they will right
but um if if you're a team out there
think about it
you owe it to yourself it's in the best
interest of the team it's the same
comment that that uh mike mayok made
last week about derek carr that we have
to do our due diligence and see if
there's an upgrade out there i feel like
every team owes it to itself to look at
the quarterback it has right now and ask
is there a way to get russell wilson and
are we one of the teams that we think
he'd want to play for i mean with the
giants with the giants do uh see you
later eli manning will will trade for
russell wilson if this is where russell
wilson wants to be and he would take
less
from the giants than he would want from
the seattle seahawks do you make that
call if you're dave gettleman and you've
got multiple first-round picks that you
could dangle well yeah yeah i i i mean
how much less is it gonna take though
you know what i mean like okay so less
so what he's not gonna get aaron rodgers
or he's gonna get aaron rodgers money
you know what i mean what is what's left
still he's still gonna be the highest
paid in league history it's just not
gonna be as much as it otherwise might
have been right yeah i know so that's
that's i don't think that's in the
giants dna to do that right now at least
i i i would be shocked you know and
again they're going to be on the hook
for some eli money too there so if you
add that on to okay we trade russell
wilson and then whatever they wanted to
do with eli either having the backup or
whatever ship them out of town i don't
even know how that would work that'd be
a lot of money on your team just you
know for the quarterback position itself
and i just don't think it's in the
giants dna to make that type of bold
move uh but maybe they can prove me
wrong
yeah i i'm just i'm fascinated that
we've gotten to this point because
this is one of the boldest all-in moves
i've seen from a player and russell
wilson would have been one of the last
quarterbacks we would have expected to
take this approach and and maybe part of
the dare here by the seahawks is whether
or not he can pull it off and maybe they
do
let it percolate and they see if he can
talk to the media and
find a way through the weeds where he
can still be go hawks guy
but also can be i want to get paid guy
because it's going to be very hard to
reconcile the two all right we're going
to take a break when we return chris
sims we will be discussing come on hurry
up
get into it i had to refresh my memory
you know instead of helping me out now
yeah that's hard hurry up we'll be back
more pfd pft lightman after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports